[Musique]
lâchez-moi au local où tu gueules bien
que ressemblant étrangement à des scènes
de la vie quotidienne
ces actes de violence feront partie de
la suite des aventures de joël nasa dans
la série kruska fait que tourne en ce
moment pour tf1 jean-claude janer sa
suffisance tirs bon tu me files tous
besoin tu veux juste entamée castanho
ils viennent fleury je pense que la
réalité dépasse la fiction
malheureusement donc là vous vous
atténuez les choses quand même non
j'étais nue pas c'est à dire que je
crois que la violence existe
actuellement et que coulonges écrit ce
scénario ya six mois
et en ce moment il ya une telle vague de
violence en banlieue je crois qu'on ait
dépassé la fiction a dépassé par la
réalité
la tournée dans une pharmacie et je
crois que le pharmacien été poignardé on
a tourné dans un bar et
poussières enfin la patronne est très
apprécié dans ces bois terre vous étiez
déchiré dans ces nouvelles aventures
véronique jannot alias joëlle mazart se
battra pour défendre et aider de jeunes
adolescents entre 16 et 17 ans qui
vivent bien souvent au bord de la
délinquance d'où un sérieux problème
pour le réalisateur celui de trouver ces
jeunes comédiens capables d'être à
l'écran des loubards plus vrai que
nature
j'ai vu 600 ou 700 jeunes comédiens j'ai
fait tous les cours il doit y avoir 40
points je vais en faire 35 plus les pour
de bon j'avais besoin de jeunes
maghrébins de jeunes noirs
donc ça on les trouve pas dans les cours
les cours sont restés bourgeois
je sonne beaucoup parce que c'est
difficile avec de jeunes comédiens ils
n'ont pas ils ont une fonction
ça c'est fantastique mais ils n'ont pas
la maîtrise corporelle et la précision
nécessaire pour prendre des places donc
je suis obligé de faire plusieurs
saisons on a demandé avec le de
production qu'à chaque fois qu'on
tournait dans un endroit spécifique
il y avait un conseiller technique alors
on a tourné à la coiffure il y avait un
conseiller technique à la mécanique un
conseiller technique en restauration
l'hôtellerie un conseiller technique
sinon moi je ne sais pas on me parle de
pistes on parle de bupa l'on parle de
maladie du cheveu maladie de la perle
j'y connais absolument rien donc il faut
vraiment sinon on aborde le monde du
travail je crois que c'est un monde très
délicat et on va faire de faute
professionnelle donc il faut un
conseiller technique
et pourquoi y at il des filles qui
tourne dans un atelier de mécanique dans
certains lycées l'enseignement
professionnel c'est-à-dire lep depuis
deux ans il ya des filles qui désirent
apprendre la mécanique et en général
c'est une ou deux journées micro et les
jeunes que vous employez voulait il
avait transposé disons de nanterre est
ici vous leur faites connaître un milieu
de cinéma oui vous ne pensez pas que sa
puce un peu les perturbés dans leur vie
future
moi je crois que c'est non le jeune jeu
par exemple précis le jeune daoudi qui
maghrébins que j'ai trouvé à nanterre me
dis tiens peut-être qu'un jour chômé
metteur en scène un comédien mais c'est
lui a ouvert une autre vie et si les pam
même metteur en scène il leur avait une
aventure je finisse
m
[Musique]